You like the US enzymes TVGO or the EGCG?
I looked it up online and came across pure encapsulations.
That's a different company TVGO.
Is this the same?
Both companies have the registered name TVGO
with the R symbol, which makes me wonder.
It is.
So pure encapsulations buys their Greek T extract from US enzymes.
Actually, US enzymes, parent company.
So, but US enzymes.
So, US enzymes sells it to pure encapsulations.
Now, we don't sell pure encapsulations for multiple reasons.
So, that's one company that.
I personally don't like doesn't mean they don't have some good supplements.
I just don't like how they run their company.
So,
but understand that even so like some of the other US enzymes products.
I mean, US enzymes sells their enzymes to a lot of different companies.
There's only three companies in the United States.
There's only three.
I'll say all the all the nutritional companies that sell enzymes.
They're getting them from three sources.
One of them is US enzymes.
And I think that is the purest source of enzymes.
So, those are the companies.
Those are the enzymes that we typically sell in the companies.
That are using US enzymes enzymes.
So, and again, I like US enzymes.
Products.
Particularly because they are so anal in their purity.
And I've told you that the EGCG that's on the market.
The green tea extract.
That's the EGCG is the catacom in the green tea extract.
That is the beneficial nutrient in green tea.
But you can't drink enough green tea to get enough EGCG to make it.
You make it, you know, a form of treatment.
And all of the green tea, all of the green tea tea that's on the market.
All of the green tea extracted every single supplement that is in existence is coming from where it's all coming from China.
Like it a lot, it's all coming from China.
And China sells some of the most contaminated products on the market.
So, if the company isn't doing their due diligence in checking and checking again and checking again.
And just being completely anal about checking for contaminants.
Most of the companies that are selling, we go to Walmart and things.
That's my struggle with them is they don't care.
These companies don't care even though they have a fancy looking label.
They don't care about the contamination of their product.
They don't even care about the product contains what it says on the label.
So, I only like TV go.
I only like the US enzymes EGCG.
Now they do sell it to other companies.
So yes, the peer encapsulations TV go.
They actually bought the ability to use the bay in two.
So they paid a little bit more.
But there's other companies that are actually using the EGCG from US enzymes.